apple and nvidia are going to war over  the claims for having the world's  fastest computer gpu with apple going  all out on performance per watt with  their 128 core m1 max quadra gpu while  nvidia is literally just throwing metric  tons of power at its upcoming rtx 4090  so let's get right into it apple is  working on much more powerful chips with  two and four times the number of cpu and  gpu cores than their current m1 max chip  and nvidia's gaming gpus are getting a  major refresh next year it looks like  nvidia is gonna have the upper hand in  terms of performance but don't forget  that they're estimating it to also  consume a lot more power if these supply  shortages continue for the next couple  of years we could actually reach a point  where it'll make more sense to buy a mac  to get a seriously high level of  graphics performance instead of trying  to find an rtx 4090 which could be in  short supply